[Music]
it takes more than mirror Dimensions
jumps through time and crash Landings to
stop the Enterprise's Legacy the
Federation flagship's history goes
deeper than you may realize
there have been ships named the
Enterprise as far back as the early
1700s such as the British Royal Navy's
HMS Enterprise in the United States the
world's first nuclear-powered aircraft
carrier was the USS Enterprise which
became a key location in Star Trek 4 the
Voyage Home the Space Shuttle Enterprise
was the first space-faring ship to Bear
the name both in Star Trek and in the
real world of course the real one was
named after the Starship in the series
thanks to a letter writing campaign from
fans with the registry of xcb330 the
first deep space Starship to go by the
name Enterprise is seen in a series of
images in Star Trek the motion picture
as well as in Captain Forest office on
Star Trek Enterprise the only physical
representation of the vessels so far is
in JJ Abrams Star Trek Into Darkness
where a model of the early Enterprise
appears on the desk of Admiral Marcus
though little is known about this
pre-federation Starship we do know that
it was based on an unused design from
series artist Matt Jeffries before he
settled on the Enterprise used in the
1966 TV series before the launch of Star
Trek Enterprise in 2001 fans had always
believed that Kirk's Constitution class
Enterprise was the first Starfleet
vessel to go by that name but in a major
retcon the series introduced start
fleet's first Flagship the nx01 proudly
bearing the name on its Hull Earth's
first ever warped 5 Starship engine was
designed by Henry Archer a protege of
the original warp drive Creator is that
from Cochran but there were many doubts
about moving forward during the engine's
development were it not for the efforts
of Henry's son Jonathan Archer and
former rival pilot A.G Robinson it may
have been scrapped altogether Jonathan
would later become the ship's first
Captain launched in 2151 on a mission to
deliver an injured Klingon back to his
people the nx01 lacked most of the
advanced technology fans are familiar
with from other shows like energy
Shields Photon Torpedoes and tractor
beams despite the is the ships still
managed to become legendary it served as
the Forefront of the zindy war Paving
the way for the Vulcans and dorians and
tellurites to eventually form the United
Federation of planets according to the
series finale this Enterprise was
decommissioned in 2161 and placed into a
fleet Museum the original USS Enterprise
may not be the first one to exist
chronologically in Star Trek Canon but
it is the most famous its groundbreaking
designed by Matt Jeffries combined
classic Sci-fi tropes to form an
instantly recognizable silhouette it was
aboard the original that Trek fans first
learned about phasers Photon Torpedoes
and Transporters but interestingly when
it was initially developed by series
Creator Gene Roddenberry it was designed
to be a ship with a history with James T
Kirk being its third Captain for three
years on Star Trek the ship traveled to
Strange New worlds seeking new life and
new civilizations while much of its
design may seem dated today the Starship
lives on in the hearts and minds of
trekkies so much so that it was lovingly
recreated in episodes of other Star Trek
series though it would see a new look
when Star Trek warped to the movies
thanks to reruns in the 1970s renewing
the series popularity a Revival of Star
Trek was launched in theaters with a
bigger budget and a bigger screen a new
design for the Starship Enterprise was
in order after some radically different
concepts were considered an updated
version of the original was chosen with
some streamlined shapes and a lot more
detail in fact the remodel of the
Enterprise serves as a major plot point
in Star Trek the motion picture the film
opens after an 18-month retrofit where
the Starship was reconstructed from
nearly the ground up as a result new
Captain William Decker objects to Kirk's
reassignment to the captain's chair
because of his unfamiliarity with many
of the new systems Admiral
this is an almost totally new Enterprise
you don't know where a tenth as well as
I do that's why you're staying abroad
sure enough his lack of knowledge does
wind up causing problems during the
refitted Enterprises first mission
eventually this updated Starship became
a fan favorite in its own right but
while Kirk was forced to destroy it to
stop a gang of maraud and Klingons in
Star Trek 3 The Search for Spock it was
replaced with the USS Enterprise a first
seen in the final moments of the 1986
film Star Trek 4 the Voyage Home the
Enterprise day is nearly identical to
its predecessor save for some interiors
and it began a long-standing tradition
of tacking on in alphabetic suffix to
new Starships in the line the next
Enterprise fan saw was the Enterprise D
which debuted just a year later in Star
Trek the Next Generation we would hear
nothing about Enterprise B until the
cast of The Next Generation moved to the
big screen themselves in 1994's Star
Trek generations I was out saving the
Galaxy when your grandfather was in
diapers
besides which I think the Galaxy owes me
one
Star Trek generations opens with the
first flight of Enterprise B A
state-of-the-art Starship of the same
class as the Excelsior in Star Trek 3
this new Enterprise was captained by
John haremu though its first mission was
originally planned as little more than a
trip around the solar system it got
forced into a rescue effort when a
strange phenomenon threatened a nearby
ship swinging into action Captain Kirk
Saves the Day sacrificing himself to
save the endangered ship though a lot of
other media has explored the Further
Adventures of Captain Harriman and the
Enterprise B including its helmswoman
damora the daughter of Captain Sulu we
have yet to learn more about it on
screen
the Enterprise C is only seen once in
the third season of Star Trek the Next
Generation in the acclaimed episode
yesterday's Enterprise Captain Jean-Luc
Picard and the Enterprise D encounter a
rift in space through which the
Enterprise C emerges having traveled
forward 22 years and altering history in
this diverged timeline the Federation is
on the losing end of a decades-long war
with the Klingons and The Disappearance
of the Enterprise sea is a big reason
why as it turns out the Enterprise C
under the command of Captain Rachel
Garrett came to the aid of a Klingon
Outpost that was under attack eventually
this action led to peace with the
Federation ultimately after Garrett is
killed in the Divergent timeline
Enterprise C returns to the pass to
fulfill its Destiny and restore history
despite history recording the loss of
all hands we've learned that survivors
from the Enterprise sea were taken
prisoner on Romulus this included an
alternate version of Tasha Yar from
Enterprise D who would eventually give
birth to the villainous Commander Sila
like its predecessor what we learn in
this episode is all we officially know
of that ship the Enterprise D of Star
Trek the Next Generation was designed by
Andrew Probert a protege of Star Wars
concept designer Ralph mcquarie
Macquarie had been hired to
conceptualize the new Enterprise for the
first Star Trek movie and recommended
Probert to join the film's design team
Probert sketched up an early idea for a
new ship that later formed the basis for
the Enterprise D nearly twice as large
as Kirk's classic Enterprise this 24th
century Galaxy class starship could go
much faster and had a new feature that
allowed the saucer to separate from the
body of the ship during a crisis the
Enterprise D was outfitted with plenty
of new technology too with its holodex
becoming a Star Trek staple it was the
first Starship to house an entire
community on board even including
schools incredibly this Enterprise also
had a group of hyper-intelligent
dolphins that helped steer the ship
though this section is only briefly
mentioned and never seen
have you had a chance to see the
dolphins yet this is
just commanded by Captain Picard the
Federation Flagship is seen through all
seven seasons of The Next Generation
along with Star Trek generations however
in the climax of the movie The
Enterprise D crashes on Viridian 3
sustaining catastrophic damage
Star Trek the Next Generation saw a few
dramatic changes during its first move
to Cinemas with Star Trek generations
but for its follow-up Star Trek first
Contact they were given a facelift in
addition to an entirely new uniform
design Picard and his crew received the
USS Enterprise E this Sovereign class
vessel marked a departure from the
smooth design of other TNG Starships in
favor of a more militant angular ship
created by illustrator John Eaves who
would also contribute to signs for Star
Trek Picard and Star Trek Discovery the
Enterprise E possessed Cutting Edge
weapons like Quantum Torpedoes it even
went toe-to-toe with the Borg on its
first Adventure Enterprise E remained
the hero of the rest of the Next
Generation films and was eventually
consigned to diplomatic duties during
the Dominion War as seen on Deep Space
Nine during its time in the movies the
crew of the Enterprise E largely
remained the same as on the Next
Generation and while we know its service
continued for some years beyond that
it's further Adventures have never been
explored officially when Star Trek
Picard premiered in 2020 it was the
first time we'd seen the franchise dip
its toe into the events that followed
its final TNG feature film many had high
hopes of seeing a new starship
Enterprise though the first two seasons
of the series didn't give audiences that
gift however trekkies finally got what
they were hoping for in the third
trailer for the show's third season a
first look at the all-new Odyssey class
starship the USS Enterprise f i now
prefer pacifism to a combat we're all
gonna die the direct successor to
Picard's enterprise scene in the films
this new flagship is the first
Enterprise to Voyage in the 25th Century
while its appearance brought Applause
from fans it's not actually the first
time we've seen it it was first
introduced in 2012 as a playable
Starship in a Star Trek Online Mission
titled The Odyssey class the design for
the Starship came from Floridian concept
artist and skull Dr Adam Isle and was
the winner of a fan contest in July of
2012 a natural evolution of The
Sovereign class it's a Heavy Cruiser
that in the game was developed to be the
most powerful Starship in Starfleet now
the design is the latest successor in
the Enterprise Legacy on screen in the
season 1 finale of Star Trek Discovery
fans got a jaw-dropping surprise with
the arrival of the classic Enterprise
commanded by Captain Pike James T Kirk's
immediate predecessor but the discovery
version of the iconic Starship was
updated for modern audiences eventually
captain pike Mr Spock and number one got
their own spin-off in Star Trek strange
new worlds set aboard this refurbished
Enterprise canonically it's the same
Enterprise that was commanded by Kirk in
the original Star Trek but this time its
differences are not the result of a
refit or maintenance overhaul according
to news site Trek movie Producers felt
it was important to update the design to
keep up with audience expectations in
the 2020s mixing retro futurism with
1960 interior design they managed to
reinvigorate the original Enterprise the
biggest changes include its swept
backness cell pylons and the physical
windows on the bridge a feature first
seen in the JJ Abrams films while just
about every aspect of the ship has been
updated set designers and artists made
sure to evoke Kirk's original in many
ways although it's divisive among some
fans for its many changes this new
sleeker ship is now the face of the 23rd
Century Enterprise in 2009 Star Trek the
Enterprise got a facelift when JJ Abrams
rebooted the franchise on the big screen
the film brought the series back to its
roots showing us an alternate timeline
where a younger Star Trek crew first set
foot on a newly remodeled Starship
Enterprise redesigned from the ground up
by concept artist Ryan Church the ship
has been dubbed the JJ prize by fans it
kept the traditional silhouette but with
bigger smoother curves and bulbous
warpnessels it's also much more
technologically advanced featuring a
clear glass view screen on the bridge
that allows the crew to look directly
into space this major departure from
previous Starship designs has since
become standard carrying over into new
ships in the prime timeline past and
future though it's initially captained
by Christopher Pike Kirk would sit in
the captain's chair by the end of the
first film and again in its two sequels
in service through Star Trek beyond the
ship was damaged Beyond repair by the
villain crawl and replaced by a new
Enterprise a which is seen only briefly
in the film's final moments given its
nature as science fiction Star Trek has
glimpsed into its own future more than
once showing us a few Enterprises
outside of the main timelines some exist
far off into a future we may never see
on screen while some exist in now erased
alternate Futures in the Star Trek the
Next Generation finale for example were
introduced to a then future version of
the Enterprise D with a radical refit
boasting three nacells and a new massive
phaser weapon under the saucer but the
most notable future Enterprise might be
one we only got a brief look at in an
episode of Star Trek Enterprise during
the zindy war storyline Captain Archer
was pulled into the far future and onto
the USS Enterprise j a ship carrying on
the Enterprise Legacy 400 years into
Archer's future according to the time
traveling agent Daniels this ship was
part of the battle that drove a
malevolent race called the sphere
Builders back to their own realm in this
future the Enterprise Jay even had
members of the zindia along its crew
though little else is officially known
about the Enterprise J the Starship
eventually made its way into the Star
Trek online game and has its own model
produced by eaglemoss with Star Trek
Discovery Now set in the 32nd Century we
may get to see newer versions of the
Enterprise even further into the future
from the past to the present and the far
future we've seen Enterprises of all
kinds but there are even stranger
versions of the Federation Flagship that
have been the focus of several
Adventures these variant vessels usually
originate in bizarre alternate realities
and parallel dimensions and they have a
long history themselves the first one
appeared way back in the acclaimed 1967
episode Mirror Mirror which saw the ISS
Enterprise under the command of a
tyrannical Captain Kirk as a whole
galaxy going crazy kind of a uniform is
this what's your beer what's going on
where's my personal guard
I can answer none of your questions at
this time that same Mirror Universe was
Revisited in a 2005 two-part episode of
Star Trek Enterprise which saw a variant
of the nx01 under the command of
Maximilian forest forest is usurped by
his first officer Jonathan Archer who
after taking over the ship gets caught
in a power struggle with the Vulcan to
Paul another time ravaged alternate
future nx01 was also seen in the
Enterprise episode e-squared though the
Next Generation never ventured Into the
Mirror Universe we did witness Untold
numbers of Enterprises from other
parallel universes in the episode
parallels one of which had been
decimated by the board
[Music]